Hey,
each Latin down had many different forms.
The accusative singular became the basic four
vulgar.
Latin boodle meant wall cost.
Summit House silent meant salt and update late art.
Every Latin Noun belong to one of three categories.
Masculine,
feminine,
and Neuter.
These categories are called genders,
but they don't necessarily correspond to physical gender.
Many words for inanimate objects where masculine or feminine and some words for
people were actually nuder.
Yeah,
romance content.
Words have a stem in an ending here.
Ooh,
AH,
eh.
Are Endings masculine or neuter?
Ooh,
feminine.
Ah,
any gender can in a vulgar Latin combined masculine and neuter.
Ooh,
into a single masculine gender.
So masculine Moodle and neuter vegetable both become masculine and the romance
languages.
Cost size,
feminine,
solid stays,
masculine and feminine
in Mediterranean Romance Languages,
masculine nouns and an or.
Ooh,
these are the modern languages.
Spanish,
Moodle,
Sardinian,
Italian Moodle,
Portuguese,
Moodle from late Latin Moodle
in eastern Spain,
France,
Switzerland,
northern Italy.
In Romania,
this masculine ending actually wears off,
so we get French move.
Romanian mood,
romantic meat.
You can see that the original ending Ou has been lost.
Feminine Nouns in,
Ah,
keep that buy in Iberia.
It'll lead southern France and Switzerland.
So Petra becomes Spanish.
Pierre Ground Italian Pietro Sardinian Pedram feminine,
uh,
gets and Catalan,
Romanian and Portuguese Pedram Piatra.
It has a sound like instead of
French,
eventually just loses this feminine.
Pierre
final also gets weaker outside of Italy.
So we have Italian at day camp at Annie's Sardinian rt,
but romance or French
or Italian silent,
but Spanish Sal French Sen
neuters remain in Romanian and a few curious cases in Italian and Romansh.
Romanian neuters have a masculine looking form in the singular but feminine life
forms in the plural.
So neuter vegetable becomes Romanian veteran,
but the plural is vetter bay.
There's an east west split in the way.
Romance languages turn basic nouns like Moodle and two plurals western romance
languages like French,
Spanish,
Occitan,
Portuguese and Sardinian add an s to the end.
This comes from the accusative plural in Latin Moodle has the accusative plural
Moodle's,
which you can see in the Sardinian Moodle's,
Spanish Moodle's,
Katelyn Mousse and French Mu.
Similarly,
the accusative plural of Casa Casa.
So Spanish cost,
Katelyn cassis and so on.
Eastern Romance languages lean on the nominative plural instead,
which is responsible for all those academic sounding Latin plurals in English
alumnus,
alumni,
alumna alumnae.
Those are the same plurals that survive in eastern romance languages like
Italian,
Sicilian and Romanian Moodle has the plural,
moody,
just as Italian Moodle becomes moody and Romanian mood has the plural mood
at a glance.
It looks like eastern romance also owes its feminine plurals to the Latin
nominative.
Latin Casa has a nominative plural Casa,
which should become romance Cassie,
but evidence points to an accusative origin.
Eastern Romance.
Last final ss.
So gases eventually changed to Italian Cozzie and Romanian Kasey.
Yeah.
What about the plurals of those nouns?
Ending in a nounce in the west still add s so we have Brazilian,
Portuguese,
acci and after cheese,
those vowels switching eastern nounce turn that a two,
n.
E.
R.
T.
That's all for the basics of masculine,
feminine and Neuter Gender and singular and plural.
Number of nouns in the romance languages.